pour les législatives c'est une
motivation totale puisque moi je suis
sur une circonscription qui est depuis
plus de 40 ans à gauche je veux amener
l'alternance nécessaire pour pour 7 pour
cette région et pour la france en
général et mon soutien est total à
françois fillon et j'ai hâte qu'on
conçoit bien sur le terrain et qu'on
montre tout notre beauty vation dans le
béarn
sur le terrain on sent que les gens de
toutes façons on vit réellement qu'est
une alternance au niveau national que
l'on puisse redresser le pays avec le
programme que propose aux françois
fillon je pense qu'il faut qu'on garde
sa dynamique il faut qu'on garde ce
courage cette dynamique pour gagner la
future présidentielle et puis ensuite
législatives qui suit une motivation
vous imaginez elle est intacte et je
vais me battre pour pouvoir récupérer
complètement 7,7 sarko pour la ramener
chez les républicains
je peux même pas imaginer que les
républicains soit pas au second tour et
après près à la présidence de la
république en fin de tout mon coeur ma
motivation est de travailler de
m'engager toujours plus au sein de cette
circonscription pour la reconquérir
et donner une vraie majorité à
l'alternance qui se dessine pour notre
pays
j'y vais aborder la campagne de manière
très simple assez pragmatique à mon
image avec des valeurs profondément
ancrée celle du travail celle du mérite
et de travailler toujours dans le
concret au service d'un territoire de
manière à pouvoir ouvrir des portes au
niveau national j'aborde cette campagne
des législatives avec beaucoup
d'humilité parce que je crois que pour
faire de la politique aujourd'hui il en
faut beaucoup je crois que les
convictions sont importantes dans la vie
publique et aussi évidemment je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure
avoir beaucoup d'humilité de la solidité
de l'humilité et des convictions
c'est un travail de longue haleine de
présence sur le terrain d'être à
l'écouté de nos concitoyens pour leur
trouver des solutions avancées sur les
dossiers etc
donc on s'appuie pour s'appuie sur un
vrai creuset qui nous qui nous fait
confiance et c'est vraiment sur cette
confiance là que je souhaite porter ma
conviction est évidemment l'emporter
dans quelques mois